paris bon tiers
quand est ce que mange quand est-ce
qu'on s'arrête quand est ce qu'on peut
se laver
bonjour à tous dame nature nous regarde
un petit caprice météo dont on se
passerait bien au mois d'août puisque
après le passage pluvio-orageux de cette
nuit et l'instabilité est toujours
d'actualité
non avec le soleil c'est bénéfique
eh ouais
m
je fais partie du sel je garde les
petits enfants je rend des services à
prat à gauche adorent ya de quoi remplir
les journées elle sera parfois même
temps assez longue pratique un peu ou la
randonnée et bientôt les l'excitation
chiens chats oiseaux poissons cochons
d'inde cobayes et lapins haut niveau a
quitté le ski la randonnée pédestre et
de la randonnée motorisée dont on
parlera aux trousses cette semaine nous
la peinture en bâtiment la réfection de
boiseries de bateaux je n'ai plus rien
mais il faut pas les manger l'un d'eux
chaque année je fais une grande rose est
tout seul dans les vosges et pour une
fois
ouais je serai accompagné entre ce sera
presque 12
le travail j'ai une double casquette
chez l'assistante de gestion et
responsable qu est-ce qui est qualité
sécurité environnement essentielle
on va dire bonjour
à l'étape du jour aujourd'hui on fait
donc une randonnée à pied qui va nous
mener dans la montagne ici on a 500 m
d'altitude au niveau de saint cloud
globalement un peu plus ici et on va
monter quasiment avec 200 m une étape
montante on va faire ça
chevrières justement et en me relevant
je ne sais pas j'ai dérapé complètement
une chute première chez je me suis pas
fait mal donc ça va on part faire partie
de vos paysages une belle randonnée avec
de belles dénivelé très très grande
très agréable pas trop rapide
voilà trop lentement c'est hyper cool
mec derrière il pas être obligé de s'en
occuper
j'aurais devenu notre cercil attitré
certes il voilà ça sert filet puis pool
pro kurde et les petites doses est doté
pour ce qu'elles ont besoin de gens
comme ça donc on est parti sur un rythme
assez lent donc vraiment nickel pour le
coup ils vont la garder tout le monde
ça a été donc j'ai pas envie de prouver
de gros problèmes de souffle randonnée
c'est plutôt baladés tout ça or la main
le fait de porter un chat sa carte est
lourd et puis de marcher des heures et
des heures on se rend compte que c'est
un sport parce que mine de rien les
muscles travaillent quand même quoi
c'est pas si les fichiers de musique
dans des halls et leur présence est
largement due à l'humidité permanente
qui règne sur ce petit versant de la
vallée
et puis comme on le disait le couvert
d'aiguilhe c'est une chose arbustes à mi
hauteur
on va le monter on fait du bien c'est
bien chaud il reste à peu près tous les
sens nous permettre de monter encore qui
nous reste encore je pense que le plus
dur est à venir
nicolas effectivement qu'ils étaient
plus soucieux que réellement
physiquement en difficulté mais à mon
avis c'est plus la question de
s'interroger si ça alors à lille jusqu'à
ce soir
palaiseau
abo
non mais stéphanie camalon qui
effectivement il se déchausser tout ça
et pour eux
on va essayer de protéger surtout on
voit où ça frotte sur son sur le pied en
enlevant les chaussures j'ai regardé ma
j'ai commencé à voir des ampoules donc
guy m'a soigné grand gentleman très
gentil et donc voilà donc c'est reparti
de nouveau pour la journée quoi
je
dès qu'il ya du dénivelé j'ai un peu de
jeu pas très endurant on est déjà
fatigué sky et astuces qui se rajoutent
activement chaque fois comment ça bon
alors l'on ressent tout de suite
bah j'ai été puni j'ai été puni je suis
je suis de corvée de ce portage de
tentes
non non c'était pour pour soulager donc
le guide on l'attend
effectivement fait partie de ces poids
difficilement compressible donc c'est ce
qui passait d'un halo donc là on trouve
la solution pour terminer la journée non
c'est bon
moi j'ai pas de pain à vous demander si
votre voisin vous conseille nomades ont
fait passer voilà c'est bon bon ben je
partirai tandis que vous avez été
transmises on va faire la vérification
je me définis au niveau des taxes visent
à faire cet élément terre un peu longue
veste
tu pourras faire en auriez facilement
ouais tu vois c'est gentil qui pendant
dix ans qui fait partie du concert
certes mais qui n'est pas forcément le
l'absolu mans nécessaire d'être aux
secours j'en ai une hausse et non mais
je crois qu'il faut pas sont pas changé
ses habitudes parce que sinon ça risque
d'être difficile donc on va rester sauf
le club espère vraiment pas rien n'est
trop n'ont rien de gros ce soir fait le
point tunisie éventuellement aux cibles
eux-mêmes y avait vraiment le strict
minimum quand il n'y avait vraiment pas
d'excès peut-être un petit peu mais mon
doudou sol couverts
on s'est parfois même passé des trucs
puissant normalement quand même
le portage reste conséquent c'est vrai
que la randonnée d'aujourd'hui et sur
des itinérances aujourd'hui on va dire
la demande ou la demande qu'on essaie de
refaire puis vous me dire on sent que ça
ça revient au goût du jour
clairement on décale sur des formules
légère de randonnée plutôt de gîtes
agite et aussi avec transport à dire
l'essentiel des bagages à la journée
nous transportons que que ce que nous
avons besoin pour ce venir à partir le
matin et revenir le soir à l'hébergement
suivant un sac qui t on là pour la
reporter pendant cinq heures
d'un coup il est bien plus inconfortable
au début c'était lourd c'est vrai après
au milieu de la balade ça allait encore
on les sentait plus après la fin de la
valeur dans le sentier c'est surtout la
fatigue aussi
guy m'a proposé de prendre du matériel
donc j'ai pris une tante qui doit faire
quand même même si elle est relativement
légère et de modèle à un peu moderne de
faire des 2 kg 5 admettant une paire de
jumelles sur cette deuxième partie de
journée on gagne monté pratiquement 400
mètres de dénivellation cet après midi
sur c'est le second passage clé de la
journée
ce qu'on a nous un premier ce matin qui
fait qu'on maintenant on est bien avancé
dans l'étape
ce rapproche tranquillement ont
tranquillement d'arrivée
oui on t'a compagnie voilà jusqu'ici
mais on vient
m
non
la faute donc si ça même sur la j'en
connais beaucoup on va dire qu'on
cultive nous et puis quel risque d'être
très belles fleurs celle là et surtout
quand on retourne la feuille
ce qui est surprenant c'est que la
feuille est également très très rose est
quasiment de la même couleur que de la
faire
voyez là sommet de cette montagne ces
trois là oh là où c'est là bas qu'on va
on l'appelle la croix les couloirs il le
temps étant radieuse ce soir il est
obligatoire du casque
c'est un incontournable ça me paraît
loin les faux oui et je me dis qu'après
on va partir lendemain mais ça
m'étonnerait coeur
le problème c'est les boîtiers qui
touche sur le côté et devant donc je les
ai peut-être prise un peu un peu trop
petite une bonne pointure trop petit
moral des troupes avancent la dernière
difficulté bon donc je trouve pas
possible il est bientôt 18 heures c'est
normal classique là je sens qu'on va y
arriver
je crois bien qu'on va y passer ouais
c'est ce qui m'inquiète d'ailleurs je
pense qu'on est tous un peu c'est la
journée dans les jambes comme on sait
très bien que delacroix on va on va voir
cette adaptation guerriers on va on aura
regardé sans noah en fait sans mettre en
pratique des musées et on sera
l'hébergement il sera une demi heure 40
minutes maximum
allez on y va
le labour pionnat ouais moi je serais
prudent ce genre de champignon se voit
énormément qui visiblement sont peu
cueilli ou pas du tout aller manger et
lola cars de réputation soit pas que ce
soit très beau très goûteux
forcément là on arrive en fin de journée
on vit on aimerait bien tous est déjà
arrivé après
le terrain nous n'est-ce pas le choix
donc ça va le faire qui deborah mais on
a échangé de chaussures tout à l'heure
je pense que deux au moins de passer la
journée pour regarder verra ça
tranquillement son sens
on revoit les bouchoux moi j'aime bien
la perspective du showbiz honeywell est
c'est dangereux et puis l'autre c'était
bien à un moment donné l'un vers le bas
vers le milieu ou à peu près du lieu je
souffle et puis après on a arrêté un peu
plus tôt le marché un peu plus penser
on y va
les vacances en soi bien pour autant il
y avait quelques passages un peu
déjà le la callas un ex imola fallait du
vigilant pour ne pas trébucher et
certains passages où qui était très
étroits avec le vide un peu son côté
gauche
moi je suis patron je pas trompé en me
disant que ça a été bon et jamal avril
mon but contenu pierre donc on regarde
les paddocks et le vertige pour moi
c'était une grande première d'avoir
franchi ces cas quoi et on voit jamais
le bout et on apprécie que les gens vont
pas tenir que le dos non plus une
fatigue ont su on est mouillé partout
ballack c'est un sacré défi que j'ai
relevé à je me suis dit si les autres y
arrive il n'y a pas de raison que j'y
arrive pas eh ben voilà les mollets vous
bien je les fais régulièrement les
étirements aux arrêts depuis sa main
le soleil c'est quand cacher on l'a vu
on voit au loin dans tous les cas sur le
bas du jura comme on dit dans le val de
saône alors âgé présent ça ça va
sûrement nous arriver dans tous les cas
cette nuit tranquillement vers is it
prot
donc composer sac c'est vrai qu'ici si
vous avez un maillot secte pas loin vous
pouvez dans cinq ou dix minutes le m ou
comment savoir france a laissé faire ça
fait pas ça c'est trop beau
non non viables aux heures d'ouverture
parce que là bas aussi facilement que
j'étais seul à le remonter ces temps ci
j'ai été aidée à droite à gauche
pour
ok 3
je sais rien je suis là je fais
paratonnerre
allez on y va
aller des barrages
j'ai quand même peur en moment donné
avec ce vent qui s'est levé
les éclairs qui nous entoure est donc là
oui j'aurais pas dû courir j'aurais dû
écouter ce qu'on m'a dit abel que la
cour eut donc la pénombre un peu bon
avec l'orage bien entendu et puis le
terrain qui est un petit peu avec des
touffes d'herbe et des pierres donc elle
n'a pas vu un trou est la chute est donc
tout de suite on a vu que ben s'était
fait mal en quelque sorte
donc ça doit être dit et puis moi on l'a
pris sous les épaules et puis on l'a
ramené disons à l'abri mais attendu que
les questionner en lisant est-ce que ça
allait aller moi je pense qu'elle est
assez solide mais effectivement moi j'ai
jamais jamais eu d'entorse ou donc je
peux pas je peux pas trop juger un don
qu'elle a l'air confiant pour demain
mais on sait la mine poche de glace mais
ça vraiment là pour le coup dur si ses
partenaires
je ne vois pas rentrer maintenant
abandonné au bout de 24 heures non pas
possible
et je veux que ça continue comme ça
qu'ils soient fiers de moi et qui voit
là montrer que je suis pas qu'une maman
que je peux être
je vais toujours des petites barbes eu
d'enfant une sportive voilà et que et
que tout est possible et leur montrer
que quand on veut quelque chose et qu'on
se donne les moyens on peut réussir et
que rien n'est impossible
- les hourras je déteste ça et souvent
en fin du conflit à l'extérieur et
effectivement je suis parti en courant
l'egypte a suivi les consignes
d'attendre le guide mais j'ai pas pu
vraiment c'était on a eu un gros coup de
pub même d'un petit peu de grain à
moudre semble on est arrivés juste vécu
racle on s'en est pris aux gones comme
on dit chez nous voilà donc à cette fin
de journée chaotique brusquement mais
bon c'est vrai que ça arrive gentiment
vous cache pas que depuis le village en
montant me suis dit que peut-être assez
vite ça pouvait arriver
le gîte ici était proche et que
dominique élimine donc ils passeront
d'ici accepte de nous mettre à
disposition une chambre y en aura pas
tous un lit dormir par terre que connaît
ensuite on a largement la tasse de venir
mais selon guo pour dormir au sol donc
mais une pile de bagdad du doigt que
c'est pour moi la soeur
français que ça passe ok super devant la
cour soir
saremi alors celle ci voit qu endurent
il est mieux que celui qui vous attend
des photos et puis la maison est
toujours ouverte à l'eau rappelle qu'on
est dans le haut jura et on a encore la
bonne idée ne pas fermer nos maisons ni
nos voitures donc le but du jeu quand
même c'est que personne ne reste au bord
du chemin
et puis les tempêtes ici sont parfois
dangereuse donc c'est quand même mieux
d'être à l'intérieur
j'ai vécu dans la vallée chameliers avec
dominique on avait peur des orages dans
les alpes
on n'aimait pas les orages dans les
alpes ici on en a peur c'est dans le
haut jura il ya deux saisons il ya
l'hiver et puis il ya le 15 août et
quelquefois le 15 août il fait mauvais
et le pot vous donner une idée des
températures le lieu que vous avez
choisi pour votre bivouac
il porte très mal son nom parce que ça
s'appelle chaude chambre c'est l'endroit
le plus froid de la paix c'est cet hiver
il y avait moins 39 la bonne soirée un
vote sur rien bon ben voilà et ils on va
parler d'un de demain demain la météo il
faut clairement bon
quand les renseignements et encore des
orages annoncés dans la nuit
donc là on s'en fout un peu et puis
demain il ya un petit risque encore
d'averses en matinée
évidemment là on sera créée dès la mi
journée l'installation du beau temps
expo
visiblement pour teaser jours ça me
semble bien engagé un teaser du top 10 à
nous classer peut-être des petits
d'homme c'est bien je viens deux
agresseurs
gerald qui est avocat la vague re
regarder ses yeux les autres donc sa
place tisanes et puis après bat son
plein libre d'aller probablement sans
prévenir mon adresse
voilà c'est très bien voilà